But the irony is that a country that's
so that's so like inclusive of feelings
will look at that Japanese person go go
back to your damn country
[Laughter]
we don't got enough Teriyaki for all you
don't like that one he was like
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys today we got Nick and clean
over there we got Anthony and Regular
Joe and then we have Cool Joe right here
let's go
okay we were just talking a little bit
before the cameras rolling about how we
measured up to our averages so like if I
were to look up the average Filipino
height that would be five one so then
I'm I stand at around five seven five
eight so yeah because we're like saying
like oh we're short we're tall and I'm
like no you gotta go based on your
ethnicity yeah yeah yeah yeah because
you can't you can't if I I'll always be
sure if I measure up to like Kenyans or
something yeah what's the average
Japanese
Kenyans instead of like black people
I was just trying to find the tallest
black people Arcadia's the tallest no I
feel like West Africans might be the
tallest because like in the Olympics
aren't they like the best uh long like
runners or whatever or like sprinting
the average the average Kenyan man
height is five seven well I'm a Kenyan
average that's the same average as
Japanese men oh five seven Japanese
Kenyan same thing you know what
um when I was in northern China there
were so so many tall people I was like
yo this short Chinese thing that might
be a southern China and that's what I am
dude I'm Southern Chinese that's right
so I'm a small small boy I saw that
thank you Colleen thank you what do you
think the average Japanese guy weighs
the average Japanese guy weighs 130
pounds dang how'd you know that because
that's what I used to be and
[Music]
people stay there longer though you know
because this I had to work for this come
on baby American diet yes definitely the
American diet yeah that's that's the
difference too we're talking even when
you're saying the Filipino men's height
average is five one you're talking about
like the Philippines you know what I
mean like what about like Filipino I
mean I'm I'm just one generation away so
I don't think I would have evolved that
fast but I think it's like American diet
American diet is a big thing because
even our bodies are so different because
um our portions are way bigger and we
grew up on the milk mustache era you
know that's true yeah we grew up on a
lot of weird food pyramid conspiracies
a lot of protein in America though you
know what I've noticed from like
traveling outside the states is that
like when I'm here I feel like I get
huge servings huge portions right and I
feel like I have to eat a lot just to
even get full and then I go overseas and
they serve me like this little ass
portion I'm like I'm gonna get full off
of this [__] yeah and then I
surprisingly I get full
and I don't understand like the quality
maybe yeah maybe that's what I'm saying
because it's just like I don't
understand how that even that's how I
felt in Japan really I was eating so
much but I wasn't gaining any weight but
you're also walking a ton out there too
no oh that I think that's a big part
yeah Americans we're really good at
sitting all day boys you got to make an
effort because this whole goddamn show
yeah that's true I get such little steps
on me yeah JK's the unhealthiest part of
my life how tall are you jump uh six two
damn way above average uh
African-American mil Heights five nine
really yeah I didn't think five nine
because he's not the American average
five eleven American average height just
enjoy I think those are the ones that
want to say I'm like six foot yeah
they're like pushing it but but if
you're five eleven if I was 5 11 I'm
like I'm six one dude I'm telling
everyone that five nine is the average
American male height yeah five nine is
the average American really okay cool
what about the way Asians are bringing
that down though you know what what do
you think the weight is
the average weight for American American
man is probably 200 200 a 185 what dude
185 185.
um it is
oh wait hold on average it keeps
freaking giving me other uh they're
giving you kilos oh those bastards
Americans giving kilos yeah right
197. I was close oh damn it's 200. you
know why five nine at 29. yeah there's a
lot of fat [__] here
there's a lot of fat [__] you know what
shocked me what the biggest shocker to
me was the average American female is
5'4 at 170. yeah that means the average
is obese five four at 170. yeah they all
got heavies
you think it's all in their boobs hey
man why you gotta say it like that dude
we're speaking code dog yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know we had actual codes for
like me and my cousin yeah we had codes
for boobs and ass what did you so like
the the codes was uh if you're talking
about a girl's boobs you would say uh
Talent oh she got a lot of time
and then if you're talking about a
girl's bottom you know the pee looks
almost like a violence to be like oh she
got a lot of potential so if she has
both silly cats
go for it well you're just like what the
[__] is wrong with her potential
that is some saggy potential
[Laughter]
codes that that I had with my friends
made things worse yeah 100 it's like
ours was when we were kids it was uh or
in high school we said credit and debit
because you know debit was the butt
[Laughter]
I'm thinking like man those Asian nerds
are so into finance and then by the time
we got to uh to college and you know
like you don't see someone for a long
time and then uh by the time you're in
college you go oh dude see what's her
name dude she got really skinny like to
not say that out loud we would say oh
she got back into drugs
you made it worse that is legit if
someone gained weight we would say oh
she's off drugs dude I do I need someone
I lost a lot of weight from drugs that's
why that's why we said that we would go
oh she looks like she got back into
drugs some drugs make you more fat yeah
that's true yeah average Chinese male
Heights five six good old school oh good
job what do you what are you Nick I
think they're pretty tall he's average 4
11. that's [__] up dude
five eleven thank you no I'm uh five
seven without shoes five eight I like
this I like how you know if you're below
six feet you really have to you have to
you gotta fight for [__] everything
you've got I'm trying to fight for
everything okay what's your height hacks
um hi hacks yeah
um when I'm sitting next to Colleen my
chair is all the way up
I was like hey make sure you slouch yeah
and I'm like hey I'm so much taller than
you Colleen and I talked with the people
hey you know what though we have long
torsos so we're usually tall stat of
sitting down because that's that's where
people get surprised when they see
Asians because they're like oh wow like
you're like normal height and then when
we stand up and then they stand out
they're like oh wait actually you're not
my Height's in my femurs we've talked
about shut up Anthony shut up Anthony
you ever see someone like sitting on a
chair and like you think their height is
gonna change and it just stays the same
needed yeah yeah
[Laughter]
yeah that's so funny
that stat is crazy to me about the
height and weight like what's the
average weight of Americans average
American weight all Americans like yeah
is half of America just fat obese and or
what is like the average death age in
America versus like uh that's good I
guess Japan fan of American
77 years oh it's not bad it's pretty
good Japan is 84. almost a decade almost
a decade yes so would you want to live
that long though like if you're healthy
yeah if it's a good 84 because dude you
see some 70 year olds that who are
really good shape or even 60 year olds
yes I would I'd be okay with skipping my
scene
that might be fun I don't want to live
long enough to forget who my kids are
yeah and I don't want to be like a
problem for my children yeah yeah I
don't want to be liability yeah I want
to be a comedy show for my kids yeah
comedy and problems can be different
things too yeah
I want to [__] on myself while I cuss
them out that's fine it's the average
what or what's the average for white
women for white women all across the
globe no death now are we talking are we
talking blondes brunette because that
matters we're talking credit debit yeah
off drugs white for like female lifespan
four for height I guess height and
lifespan height and lifespan let's see
average height for a blonde American
woman five four
and I guess lifespan is kind of all over
the place but for America it would be
like 79 years
okay 80 wait this one says 80 years wow
long life yeah
way to go keep it up keep it up is there
like a uh a googleable weight average by
Nations like obesity by Nations well
it's probably the United States top dogs
yeah you know what it's probably top
three UK is up there probably right oh
you want to see like who weighs the most
America it's Polynesia polynita for sure
usually Polynesia is the top yeah
it's by population right oh true
just the the stats and the data the
fattest country is I think Samoa
because you were saying that a lot of
the the food that they can get out in
Samoa and all those places are mostly
like processed long shelf life stuff
right I yeah all the island ones in the
same way in life because they're not
eating how their ancestors did
where it's just like raw fish and
coconuts coconuts yeah bro like in L.A
we have we're so spoiled in all the food
choices that we get but once you go
outside and like certain parts of
California or even like the Midwest you
realize everything that's available is
all fast food it's all Subways and
Chick-fil-A so in the chart in the top
chart of like obesity
like the first 13 are all like eyelid
Nations like
French Polynesia
um yeah American Samoans this is just
harder to get but then 14 once it stops
being island nations is America let's go
baby
but then if you think about it
population wise yeah yeah yeah those 13
Nations still doesn't add up to like
even a speck of American population
right so that means out of 300 million
that's a lot of fat folks yeah yeah
right when you look at just America
because that's um in U.S it's 36 percent
of us is obese I didn't realize how fat
America was because like you know when I
we've all traveled right but like other
people's perception of America is
different from us going out right so
like I don't notice how big people are
until people come here and go damn
there's a lot of fat people here you
know what's interesting
from like overseas
oh [__] fat though yeah yeah but you
know what's crazy we got TV shows for it
right that number that's just men if you
switch it to female then America becomes
number 30. number 30. yeah so there's Le
so there's more obese men than female
maybe because of like a beauty standard
more obese but then yeah but it could be
that too but also the once you put it to
a female then what takes place before
America is like uh the Emirates like
Kuwait Qatar Jordan Saudi Arabia Bermuda
Egypt uh United area maybe because they
don't go out because aren't aren't they
just supposed to stay out in the house
all day
yeah like culturally yeah there's like
it's more less it's like less they can't
show their body off anyway yeah maybe
they don't even know yeah they ain't got
different they got different standards
yeah it's it must be so different that
too yeah maybe it's a standard maybe
it's like hey is your wife movies yes
[Laughter]
yeah whatever you want get out yes yes
very obvious yes please leave
it's like that too it could be
because I think like
it's where it's hard to just walk like
in America you have to make an effort to
walk unless you like live in New York
you gotta go to the park and [__]
walk or you're gonna walk around your
block but then like everything's not
built in a way to just walk every day
what country do you think has the least
percentage of obese women obese women
women
yeah Vietnam whoa damn wow really oh
yeah is it Vietnam oh [__] yeah it is
2.7 because I was just thinking about a
country that had the skinniest people
that I've seen what how did you know
because it well guys and girls there
he's the census they're pretty skinny
wow wow what do you think what do you
think's next stop from Vietnam
you'll probably get this one right too
it's the next step one [__] Cambodia
or some [__] I was gonna say Cambodia or
Philippines no Philippine no not
Philippines fat yeah they like the
Jollibee no they're not they're like
um I think their diets are just like a
Thai
nope Japan yeah okay
Japan because they walk a lot and they
they do a lot of fat shaming there it's
pretty funny they'll roast you dude if
you're just fat they'll just like
strangers would just be like hey what's
up fat [__]
and that slang in English
that's the only English they know only
Japanese
only Japanese
and it's a perfectly
they're so polite about it yeah
like being fat is pretty rare out there
right so like so like you're either a
sumo wrestler or like or you're playing
a villain in the movie it's like really
rare yeah so then when my mom was here
she said that like it was so funny
because there was so many fat people
right yeah and then so when I was a kid
she like she thinks just being fat is so
funny so they'll be a guy like you know
sometimes like out here we got it's
excessive bro like it's so big that
dude's got like the [__] scooters and
[__]
so she'll if she finds one she starts
blasting up and pointing at him and she
goes honey look look look right and then
I'm there as a kid like embarrassed as
[__] and I'm like oh don't point and
then she goes oh he can't speak Japanese
and I'm like yeah but you're so obvious
you're pointing yeah yeah he knows why
you're pointing I mean we enable that
[__] though right it's like if you're
too fat then yeah you get a scooter and
a handicap sign to park closer so you
can walk less I think that's the
difference too is it not only like if
you think about being from Japan three
percent of people are obese and then you
come to a place where it's one in three
yeah there's no fat people and there's a
point of Pride about it yeah that's the
part that'll really trip you out yeah
like not only that not only are the
numbers high but like they're owning it
yeah especially when it to their their
eyes it's like this is seen as unhealthy
and unfavorable and then yeah you see
people patterns and you're healthy here
yeah yeah I don't know man that's body
positivity right in a in a country that
obviously is a big yeah which is like a
funny way of dealing with it you know
just change the acceptance exactly but
leave the death rates the same right
yeah all the heart problems are still
fine yeah nobody wants to see all that
stuff no no nothing behind it you know
yeah it's it's really interesting I feel
like we're more feelings-based country
oh yeah very we're very big in our
feelings I feel fat but
someone's gonna punch you in the face
but the irony is that a country that's
so that's so like inclusive of feelings
will look at that Japanese person go go
back to your damn country
laughing at me you twig yeah yeah yeah
I'll sit on you we don't got enough
Teriyaki for all you
Joe didn't like that one he was like
that's a hurt the feeling
so you gotta bring up teriyaki
yeah really not enough and then after
Japan it's Korea five percent yeah I
would imagine I heard China's obesity
problem is rising because they had a um
they never had a middle class and now
they do they're like they have money to
spend so a lot of them are just pounding
food can I say something about about
Asian people in the states in L.A do we
have to prepare for this in any way okay
whenever I this is the point I'm gonna
bring up anytime I go to like a nice
restaurant and I see a ton of Asian
people in there I go this is gonna be a
good restaurant because I know a lot of
Asian people are just such Foodies and I
think in China is probably the same
thing they're such Foodies that they get
like
food obsessed and we kind of are too you
know like Americans are very food
obsessed but yeah I mean I think with
with wealth comes like more food options
because my grandma was telling me
um in her generation they ate different
things meaning like she's like the
younger kids they like a lot of protein
she's like when we were growing up there
wasn't that like red meat was expensive
sure yeah it was like luxury yeah she
goes back then they used to eat whale
like once a week because weekly it was
cheaper to get whale than cow whale
Wednesdays
yeah my aunt was like when I was growing
up a lot of us ate whale not working
branding yeah and I'm like why yeah like
cow meat was so expensive because if you
think about it there's no there's no
fields for like the cows and then the
cows are foreign you got to have them
shipped over and all imported yeah yeah
for them so that's why and then they're
like now all everyone's eating beef
she's like that was this is a new thing
like we're not with any beef a lot and
then she's like uh we probably didn't
eat meat every day either she's like a
lot of vegetarian stuff so then now like
he's like you got beef bowls you got
hamburgers you got hot dogs she goes you
have more Western Foods yeah you know
what's interesting too and this is not
you know not to overlook this very
specific detail but uh what you get for
your money out here if you're poor you
can still be so fat off of how poor you
are there's definitely something wrong
with our nutrition because like most
countries poor correlates with skinny
yeah but here we have like the fattest
homeless people in the world
how the [__] does that happen well like
bro you walk into 7-Eleven which is the
greatest store of all time in the world
and you walk in and you see the food the
the fresh food they have like a taquito
is like what like 300 calories each you
get three of those things four for a
dollar come on dude yeah that's not bad
that's enough calories for you to last
your day Loki 7-Eleven wings or bomb
7-Eleven is the greatest store of all
time dude I don't wanna do they still
have a whole pizza for eight bucks six
bucks isn't it oh goodness depending on
what time of night you're there yeah bro
you get the whole the whole thing
should we go to 7-Eleven for lunch all
right oh my God but dude that's that's
really that's a really interesting thing
is the fact that like like I was saying
you go to other countries you could
probably eat the same amount that would
fill you up but you you're definitely
better for McDonald's you get you get
two McChickens for like [__] three
bucks three bucks each of those are 400
calories you could just be eating
honestly you could probably just be
homeless eating nothing but Mission Food
like free food and you'll probably still
be fat like refried beans and [__] just
whatever they're giving you because like
the the quality of food out here well we
don't have that many restrictions like
what Japan and Europe and they they
don't like there's certain food
colorings and chemicals and things
there's so much more additives I think
they care about their people
it's not even that it's just like it's
easy it's I think it's just people see
an opportunity to make money yeah if we
get mass-produced chicken nuggets at
this Factory and sell it for a fraction
of the price and sell it in bulk and
makes a delicious but that's the thing
is like when you're you're a consumer
you're like oh I can get so much more
value for this bag of dino nuggets for
five bucks we probably just need a
redefined value
you hear about that uh genetically like
uh made freaking meat that the fda's oh
yeah yeah yeah the lab meat yeah they
just need to do that but it's like got
some weird chemicals in it that make
people burn fat and then it's ooh diet
meat yeah once they could find a way to
tap into that it's over but I don't
think they will just the fact that you
can eat exotic animals that are made in
a lab is pretty crazy too it's so weird
and not feel bad about it because it's
just a simulation miss me with that
about it you know that
thank you